the 2016 BT Awards pay tribute to Prince  Qi Sunday's show was full of celebration  in honor of the late 57 year old singer  the roots Stevie Wonder and Tori Kelly  were just a few who took the stage to  pay their respects in song  Jennifer Hudson beautifully belted out  Purple Rain but nothing compared to  Janelle monáe's unforgettable medley in  an all-white Prince inspired ensemble  I'm here really to pay respect and love  and honor to a friend to a mentor not  someone who's inspired us all he's a  musical hero and I I'm here with you  know here to celebrate him Prince's  close friend and longtime collaborator  Sheila E closed out the show